thank you
you've been doing this for all of our
guests with our introduction he is the
former NFL defensive lineman Mike and
Mike co-host on ESPN radio and now he's
going to be with his son Mike Jr it's
Gojo and Golic and they'll stream daily
from 8 to 10 on the East Coast Samsung
TV plus and draftkingsnetwork.com
wait oh sorry come on let's go let
Michael
Mike Golic is here Big Mike is here
took away Paulie's little toy there uh
your your medium Mike you're not Big
Mike anymore what uh what you're playing
with right now I'm about 2 25 2 30. I'm
I'm at my high school weight my senior
year in high school weight and I
attribute it to the fact that
it I've come to realize that she won't
admit it but I'm worth more to my wife
alive still oh so she's feeding me well
having me be in shape and that whole
thing so as soon as she starts feeding
me garbage food that's when I start
sleeping with one eye open that's when
we bring in that Dateline comes yeah
that's exactly right so I'm going to
write a little note if you don't see me
help it's my wife oh that pesky DNA
uh what was your maximum playing with so
I went into the NFL 7275 and I finished
it about 300 with the dolphins felt good
uh at 300 and then
um I'd say I retired but the league
retired me when nobody calls you you're
retired uh and I kept eating and
drinking like I was playing because you
could just burn it off and probably two
years after I was done playing I was
about 34 or 35. I literally got out of
the shower one day and I looked at
myself and I looked like a vanilla
milkshake I mean it was it was
disgusting and I was about 3 18 320. uh
and and I knew I had had to start losing
some weight but you look at Players now
and it feels like defenses are smaller
yes I mean that now it's speed but do
you think we'll have a shift where
offenses will go let's counteract your
speed with power so this is what's
happening when I was playing The Edge
rusher of today wasn't in the league we
called them a tweener and there was no
place for them they they weren't big
enough to be a DN and they were too big
to be a linebacker Dwight Freeney right
I mean in my era he would have been that
tweener guy like kind of where do you
put them and now we've shifted to this
so what's happening and this is I think
one of the reasons of the devaluation if
that's a word someone help me of the
running back is offenses now are spread
out and we're passing the ball more so
the value of the running back can be
more in the receiving part like Christy
McCaffrey who leads the way there is or
an Austin Eckler type person so and the
defensive rushers are smaller
everybody's a little smaller so the
lineman oh linemen sometimes can be a
little smaller so they can dance with
them more so what's going to happen it
can be cyclical now that you have a
smaller defense that's spread out so
what do you do start to run the ball say
okay they're smaller and they're spread
out we're going to start to hammer the
ball so maybe the running game comes
back a little bit you're starting to
tighten it up and maybe you guys start
to get bigger because this is one of the
things that went on with Fritz Shermer
God Rest his one of the great D
coordinators he would he would want to
draft bigger cornerbacks when bigger
receivers were coming out to handle the
bigger receivers so yeah it all becomes
cyclical of size and how the game is
played and you were able to be a part of
those teams with Reggie White we were
talking about this yesterday that he
might be underrated you know I he could
be the greatest defensive player of all
time I know LT might have been more
impactful right but if you're looking at
Mean Joe Greene uh Reggie White
longevity doing it two different teams
at a very high level where would you how
would you categorize listen Reggie White
Reggie White Tumi is the greatest deal I
mean I've ever seen play I mean this and
and a better person again God Rest his
soul I've lost five guys off that
starting defense I mean it's just it's
it's horrible but this guy was six six
three fifteen I watched him run a four
six forty he was always the strongest
Lifter on the team he'd bench power
clean and squat and that would basically
be it he could line up at end D tackle
no tackle in that 46 defense be the
strongest guy be the quickest guy be
whatever you wanted him to be it was he
was he was one of the most amazing
athletes I've ever seen play and he
threw people around Jason Garrett was
with us and he said that Larry Allen's
rookie year Reggie is one of the
greatest yeah the greatest offensive
lineman in history and he's tossing
Larry Allen around it's that's his
strength and leverage that's a leveraged
move because you you go up the field so
hard with the rip you get the old Lyman
running with you so now you use the old
Lima's momentum and weight against him
and come back with the club and catch
him and these guys were going horizontal
it's scary to see it to do to for Larry
Allen again I re I retired the year
before or was retired the year before
Larry Allen came in the league and was
almost thankful I'm like that dude
didn't want to just block you he wanted
to kill you uh and to watch uh you know
Reggie hoist him was absolutely amazing
I'm also curious about players now and
preseason that Andy Reid wants his
starters to play but if you're trying to
make a team and Mahomes is out there
are you trying to make the team and
maybe take a shot at my home like I I
would be concerned about you got three
games to prove yourself to make a roster
there is that something that would have
entered your mind trying to make the
roster when you were drafted if I'm
playing against my home yeah I'm trying
to destroy him yeah absolutely I don't
care if he's on the other team I don't
care if it's Patrick or Holmes my first
tackle in the NFL was Walter Payton and
when I did it I didn't even realize it
was Walter Payton and now later in the
game you know he made me look foolish
which you do to a lot of people but yeah
I I mean when I went to Notre Dame Blair
Keel was the quarterback and they had
the red shirts on I was a true freshman
and and I was one that played a bit as a
freshman the first scrimmage I passed
rush and smoked him in the back
Blindside them and I mean the fight that
broke out and the coach is yelling at me
and then I realized you're not supposed
to hit a quarterback of the red jersey
on but if you're on the other team in
one of these preseason games especially
and you know players know more than
anybody else they're writing on the wall
of where you are in the pecking board
and what you need to do hell yeah I'm
trying to make a play on that guy to
make the team I don't care who it is
we're talking to Mike Golic uh medium
Mike Golic not Big Mike Golic anymore
you're going to go back into the
mornings with uh with your son I don't
know what this is like now I announced
that in four years I'm going to doing
this on a daily basis I worry that when
you wake up
you have such a routine and then you
don't have that routine and I didn't
know what that was like for you and your
wife well I mean 25 years between doing
morning radio in Arizona before I went
to ESPN and doing all the years there
4 15 every day for 25 years and it took
me a few months to kind of not at least
open my eyes at that time and then go
back to sleep but you get out you get
out of it pretty quickly out of your
routine you find other things to do now
when I left ESPN in 2021
I I was 58 years old and I I didn't want
I like my wife said well you can just
sit around all day or you know you got
you want to do something so I've been
tinkering and you feel sorry for
yourself uh
you know it's like I I equate so much to
football and when I was at the Houston
Oilers and they they cut me right so I
don't have a say in the matter they cut
me now I left Philadelphia on my own I
was a free agent then I got cut by the
Oilers I mean by the Dolphins and that
that was the end of my career people
asked you know how when you left ESPN I
said It felt the same way they cut me
you know my contract was up they didn't
want to renew it so I was like it felt
like a football uh Team where they
didn't want me anymore your pride gets
hurt because they don't want you anymore
and then at some point you want to find
something to do like when I left from
Houston to go to Philly I didn't really
care about Houston anymore but there's
part of you that wants to play well to
say you made a mistake of of getting rid
of me I didn't think of that much with
ESPN because I spent so much time there
I I loved so many people there a couple
people I didn't
um you know more on the management side
but you know that's really true or
anywhere nobody nobody is singing
Kumbaya with everybody in a company so
you have the people you're really dig
and some people you don't but I just had
to kind of move on and say what do I
want to do next and I didn't think I
wanted to do a Daily Show again but you
know as I had said I started there
working with Tony Bruno our buddy Tony
Bruno and then Greenie for so many years
and then Trey wingle and my son the most
fun I had I mean my God I get to work
with my kid yeah I mean we'd flip on the
microphone at 6am and there I am talking
with my son you know so now we're going
to do that again for two hours every
morning so
I'm not I'm not passing that up yeah see
I I love the grind I love every day like
I'd rather hit golf balls than play golf
like I I love that grind every single
day like what do we have three hours
make it happen so when I had left ESPN
and was really kind of just doing
interviews here or there every now and
then I do an interview and I'd be
talking and talking and I'd come
upstairs my wife would be like you got
to get back into something because you
just have too much to say so it's the
same thing especially when something
happened you want an outlet to talk and
I didn't have one so I'm I'm with you
there I I kind of I did kind of miss
being able to kind of verbalize you know
what I was what I was thinking and also
when it's too raw when you leave now I
left on my own decision right but then
there's still there's that raw like I'm
still mad at something or somebody sure
and you got to shut up yeah but I didn't
shut up when I left I was like out the
door and I'm still you know had issues
there I mean I I listen I I didn't want
Mike and Mike to end and then it ended
but it wasn't my choice I didn't want to
be done at ESPN but again it wasn't my
choice so at some point you have to
realize well I can't do anything about
it but that pride thing and that where
you say Okay I want to show you that was
a mistake whether it ends up being true
or not I have no idea and I I try and
not burn a bridge too much you know and
because there's my wife's always like
you need to write a book and I said no I
don't I said because when you write a
book it has to be salacious and they
want names and they want things that
happen and I'm I'm never going to do
that publicly give me the reason why
Notre Dame should join a conference
they shouldn't
um but I'll tell you is there a reason
why there's there's three reasons well
there'll always be three reasons why
they won't
obviously we know the number one money
right if you're making enough money on
your own and they're probably looking
for a 50 60 million they want more but
they probably end up I'd say 50 60
million dollars on their own is this
from NBC probably yes I would say so
okay uh they're probably looking for
look at our the home for the rest of
your sports they have one now in the ACC
so that's good and then ease to get into
the college playoffs well that's going
to expand because you're going to 12
teams now they'll never have a first
round buy because they'll take the top
four conference Champs one two three
four with a buy five through twelve will
play but they can be five six seven or
eight and they'll get a home game in the
first round and they'll be good with
that so if those things start to change
money not as good not as much ease into
the playoffs that's another thing about
a conference and if it's a conference it
in my eyes it'll be the Big Ten that
makes the most sense but until then why
and I'll say this Dan everybody that
kind of doesn't like Notre Dame and
always likes to throw barbs and sure
some in this room are like that you just
you know if you want to admit it great
yeah I don't yeah oh there yes no that
was yesterday with Will Ferrell oh yeah
yeah I saw Brady Quinn with the picking
him up off the ground defending ND and
there was no low grab there by by any
any stretch it looked like Brady was
going uh
a little too what Notre Dame is
independent and the rest of their sports
are in a conference that's what needs to
happen in all of college football
division one separate football let now
you let the Pac-12 teams do all their
Olympic sports in the Pac-12 for the
ease of travel I mean now you've got you
got the Cal Stanford USC uh I'm sorry
Stanford USC uh not Stanford USC USC
UCLA Oregon and Washington going to the
big they're flying to Rutgers for Stuff
their volleyball team I like we always
mention it's Rutgers they have to go to
well that's the furthest East is it not
or is it Penn State uh probably Penn
State Rutgers is Rutgers is so see that
my geographical knowledge there like so
I picked yeah they had to fly there so
everybody be independent football wise
and you can stay in your conference in
the other sports and you still divvy up
the money that's what they need to
figure out is how you're going to divvy
up the money and by the way we're
talking about schools you were never
known as the maple missile I think it
was the fraudulent flyer wow fraudulent
why why why where what are we doing here
I don't know
about your wife I loved your wife and I
I threw a shot at you last night I know
you know what I'm sorry but I'm not
because I'm I'm not going to go greeny
on you here
I'm beginning to return fire I won't do
that uh speaking of controversies Reggie
Reggie Bush wants his Heisman back we've
got a problem with Reggie uh wanting his
husband he should get his Heisman back
it's the stupidest thing in the world we
all know he was the best player in the
country that year I mean it's it the
NCAA listen they're a joke anyway
they're they're controlling nothing they
were all punches pilate when the nil
came around wash their hands if it said
you conferences handle it all they do is
deal with you know Jim Harbaugh buying a
burger for a kid in a dark period and
you know going to get suspended it's a
joke taking vacating wins seriously I
mean taking your Heisman away it's a
joke he should have his Heisman without
question I just never understood you
punish the kids who have nothing to do
with Reggie Bush so he you know what
that decision dismantled USC for over a
decade it's exactly right yeah yeah
Carol leaves all of a sudden you take
away all those scholarships I my point
is if USC the alumni the fans want
Reggie to have it back because they're
the ones that got hurt right right so if
you say Hey you want him to have it back
then let him have it because you you
can't take away the Fab Five but you can
take down a banner exactly you can take
away the memories we all know what they
did yeah we all know about the Fab Five
we all know Reggie Bush was the best and
deserved that trophy so yeah I'm not a
big fan of how they do that that little
kind of garbagey stuff would you have
asked for money coming out of high
school now an nil yeah oh hell yeah I
was actually a a shockingly enough a big
recruit coming out of Ohio uh so I
definitely would have asked for nil
money Dan it has changed and I'm I'm
great I'm fine with nil because I have
no problem with the guys getting paid
what I always said is I never want the
schools to pay the kids because then all
of a sudden other sports are going to be
gone you know because they're not going
to be affordable fund those schools
because they're paying football and
basketball players so I'm fine with nil
but you throw everything into another
bucket or or another thing in the bucket
I heard you know Brady talking about
Brady Quinn talking about it on your
show is what does an 18 year old do if
you get offered a million bucks to go
play somewhere and in other schools you
know as an NL for 500 000. you know
we're asking an 18 year old to make a
think about sit down and make a really
you know thought about well thought out
decision I mean we don't know where he's
coming from to what kind of guidance
does he have
so I don't know if you're going to get
the best decision out of an 18 year old
they just might see the money and say
I'm going to take the money so it's
added another dimension to what these
these 18 year olds have to think about
of where they're going and then if it
doesn't work they transfer right away
and go on the portal again I have no
problem with that coaches that complain
about the portals making this tough
nil's making it tough I don't want to
hear it you all make five six seven Mill
a year you sign a seven year deal and
two years later you jump ship and go
somewhere else and you can coach for
decades these players have four or five
years to do their thing so if they feel
they need to move around and some of
them overthink it and make a mistake by
moving but they should have the right
and the ability to try and move around
to get seen because as we know two
percent make it to the NFL 98 think
they're going to make it to the NFL
which is fine so they try and put
themselves in position to to be seen I I
just hope they all understand the
education part of it as well of how that
can carry you if and when you don't make
it and I wonder I've been saying this
all along that what's stopping a
billionaire from giving a let's say 50
million dollars a year to a collective
and saying go out and buy whatever you
want to with that money
nothing right nothing until they put up
some guidelines and guard rails and they
put a cat would you be okay with the cap
that would be interesting wouldn't it a
salary cap I mean I mean then we're
getting into are we going to get into
them being employees of a school if
they're employees now you're going to
get into unions what the Northwestern
players tried a few years ago now you
need a head of a union I mean you're
going to start to really go down a road
I don't know if you want to go down but
there's collectives everywhere how well
I mentioned just Spencer Brady Quinn
he's helping with the the collected the
fund at Notre Dame yeah
um so it's just a matter of what players
want going in are they looking to cash
in for all the money they can are they
looking at a most blue chippers look at
schools that are going to give them an
opportunity to play they'd like to win
and get a good look going to the NFL now
you just threw money into the equation
but yeah I mean this is a time for
alumni what we've done is we've taken a
bag of money that was under the table
and we've now put it on the top of the
table he's medium Mike Golic the former
NFL defensive lineman Mike and Mike
co-host on ESPN radio and now he's going
to be working with Mike Jr it's a Gojo
and Golic it's streaming 8 A.M to 10 a.m
on East Coast on Samsung TV plus and
draftkingsnetwork.com it's great seeing
you I'll see you probably tomorrow night
at the game you definitely will thank
you for stopping by I love it thanks
he's Mike Golic take a break play of the
day up next here on The Dan Patrick Show
[Applause]
foreign